there
hmm
okay
so
so
oh
okay
family
oh
this
this
oh
hey emily it's marcy gonzalez from news
one how are you
hey how's it going
i'm good thanks i'm trying to call into
your ifb number and it's not
working
uh
uh
person from virginia stand as the member
designated by dr
schreier pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that dr schreyer
will vote yes on
hjres107.
no mitchell
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from florida rise
as the member designated by mr lawson
pursuant to h.r
965 i informed the house that mr lawson
will vote yes
on hr resolution 107.
as the member designated by ms castor
pursuant to house resolution 965
i informed the house that miss caster
will vote yes
on resolution one zero seven
for what purpose does the gentleman from
maryland rise
i have paul pursuant to house resolution
965. i informed that's miss jayapal will
vote eye on
hj res 107. as the member designated by
mr pokhan pursuant to hr 965 i inform
that's mr pocan
for its eye on house joint resolution
107.
as a member designated by mr doggett of
texas pursuant to house resolution 965
and former nasa mr doggett votes i on
h.j
107. as the member designated by mr
mcnerney pursuant to
hr 965 i inform the house that mr
mcnerney votes
i on h.j res107 and is the member
designated by miss fletcher pursuant to
hres 965
and former house the ms fletcher will
vote i on h.j res107
is there for what purpose
is a general person from colorado rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr joe nagoos of colorado
pursuant to hrs 965
i informed the house that mr degoose
will vote
yes on h.j res 107.
for what purpose is the channel person
from uh connecticut rise
um mr speaker uh this member designated
by mr adam smith
from washington state pursuant to house
resolution 965.
i inform the house that mr smith will
vote yes and h.j rez107
for what purpose is the gentleman from
michigan rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr ryan
of ohio pursuant to hres 965 i informed
the house that mr ryan will vote yes
on h.j res 107. as the member designated
by mr kilmer of washington pursuant to h
res 965 i informed the house that
mr kilmer will vote yes on h.j res107
as the member designated by mr heck of
washington pursuant to atres 965 i
inform the house
that mr heck will vote yes on h.j res
107.
as the member designated by miss
lawrence of michigan
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
that ms lawrence
will vote yes on h.j res 107.
as the member designated by mr peters of
california pursuant to adress 965 i
informed the house
that mr peters will vote yes on h.j res
107.
[Music]
right
for what purpose is a gentlelady from
michigan rise
as the member designated by dr oz
of california pursuant to hres 965 i
inform the house and mr reyes will vote
i
on h.j resolution 107.
[Music]
oh
for what purpose is the gentlelady from
kansas rise
mr speaker is the member designated by
miss howland pursuant to hres 965. i
informed the house that miss holland
will vote i
on h.j res 107. as the member designated
by mr kim
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that mr kim will vote i on
h.j rez107 as the member designated by
miss axne
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that miss axne will vote
i on h.j res107 as the member designated
by mr defazio pursuant to hres 965 i
informed the house that mr defazio will
vote i on h.j res107
and as the member designated by mr
cleaver pursuant to hres 965 i informed
the house that mr cleaver will vote i
on hjres107
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california rise
mr speaker is a member designated by
miss issue
pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that miss essue
will vote yes
on h uh j res
107. want a minute
for what purpose is the gentlelady from
texas rise
mr speaker is the member designated by
ms escobar of texas pursuant to house
resolution 965.
i inform the house that miss escobar
will vote yes on
h.j res 107. mr speaker as a member
designated by
ms robert allard of california pursuant
to house resolution
965. i informed the house that ms robot
allard
will vote yes on house j
res 107. thank you mr speaker
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california rise mr speaker is the member
designated by mr garamendi
of california pursuant to house res 965
i inform the house that mr mindy will
vote yes
on h.j rez107
[Music]
for what purpose is the gentlety from
minnesota rise
mr speaker as a member designated by ms
craig
of minnesota pursuant to house
resolution 965.
i informed the house that member craig
will vote
yes on h.j resolution 107.
as a member designated by mr peterson in
minnesota
pursuant to h resolution 965
i informed the house that mr peterson
will vote yes
on house on h.j resolution
107.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
massachusetts rise
mr speaker is a member designated by mr
welsh of vermont pursuant to hres
965 i inform the host that mr welsh will
vote yes
on h.j res107 as the member designated
by mr kennedy of massachusetts
pursuant to hres 965. i inform the host
mr kennedy will vote yes
on hj res107
[Music]
for what purpose is the gentlelady from
connecticut rise
as the member designated by miss wilson
pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that miss wilson
will vote yes
on h.j res107
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from massachusetts rise
as the member designated by ms brownlee
pursuant to hres
965 i inform the house that ms brownlee
will vote yes
on h.j res 107 as the member designated
by ms bonamici pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that ms bonamici
will vote yes on h.j rez107
as the member designated by ms frankel
pursuant to hres 965 i
inform the house that ms frankel will
vote yes on h.j rez107
as the member designated by ms ming
pursuing to hres
965 i informed the house that ms mang
will vote yes
on h.j res107
[Music]
oh
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from new jersey rise
as the member designated by mr lam
pursuant to atres 965 i
informed the house that mr lamb will
vote yes on
h.j res107
yes
therapist is a gentle lady from delaware
rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr get
of colorado pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that mr get will
vote yes
on h.j res 107.
what purpose is the gentlelady from
california rise
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
desogne
pursuant to age press 965 i informed the
house that mr desanie will vote yes on
h.j res107
[Music]
whole purpose is the gentlelady from
pennsylvania rise
as the member designated by ms wall
wilde pursuant to hres 965 i informed
the house that ms
wilde will vote yes on h.j res107
as the member designated by ms speer
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that mrs pierre will vote yes on
h.j res107
as the member designated by ms davis
pursuant to hres
informed the house that ms davis will
vote yes on h.j res107
and as the member designated by ms dean
pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that ms dean will
vote yes on h.j res107
ready for what purpose is the gentlelady
from virginia
rise thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr mckeach and pursuant to
house resolution 965. i inform the house
that mr mckeecham will vote yes
on h.j as the member designated by ms
porter pursuant to house resolutions 965
i informed the house and his porter will
vote yes
on h.j res 107 and as the member
designated by mr allred pursuant to
house
resolution 965 i informed the house that
mr allred will vote yes on hj res107
[Music]
[Music]
for what purpose is the gentlelady from
hawaii stand
as the member designated by mr gates
pursuant to hres 965 i
informed the house that mr gates will
vote nay on h.j res107
[Music]
hey
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new jersey rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman pursuant to
hres965 i informed the house that miss
watson
coleman will vote yes on h.j rez107
and as the member designated by mr albio
series pursuant to hres 965
i am for the house that mr series will
vote yes
on h.j res 107. and mr speaker as the
member designated by mr bill pascrell
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that mr pasquale will vote yes on
h.j res 107.
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
virginia rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss titus of nevada
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that miss titus
will vote yes on h.j rez107
okay
thank you
for what purpose does the gentleman from
rhode island rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms pingree chair of the congressional
arts caucus of maine pursuant to house
resolution 965.
i inform the house that miss friendly
will vote yes on house resolution 107.
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms sewell of alabama
pursuant to house resolution 965. i
inform the house that missoula will vote
yes on house resolution 107.
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms delbene of washington
state pursuant to house resolution 965 i
inform the house that mrs delbany will
vote yes on house resolution 107.
ready for what purpose this gentleman
from california rise
mr speaker is a member designated by dr
bera pursuant to house resolution 965.
i inform the house that dr barrow will
vote yes on h.j
res107
this is gentleman from massachusetts
rise
good evening mr speaker as the member
designated by the honorable mr james
langevin of rhode island
and pursuant to house resolution 965 i'd
like to inform the house that
mr landerman will vote yes on house
resolution
107 further additional continuing
appropriations act of 2021.
thank you
oh my gosh
for what purpose is the gentlelady from
new york rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms
kelly pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that ms kelly will
vote
yes on hres 107.
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
for what purpose is the gentleman from
illinois rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva
uh pursuant to hres965 i informed the
house that mr grijalva
will vote yes on a hj res 107.
for what purpose is the gentleman from
california rise
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr gottheimer pursuant to
atres965
i inform the house that mr gottheimer
will vote i
on h.j res107
okay
um
[Music]
for what purpose is the gentleman from
virginia rise
mr speaker as the member does today by
ms moore pursuit with his 965
and the house of ms moore will vote yes
on hga res107
as the member does the obama mr kind
pursue at the hr 965 and reporting the
house of mr kind will vote yes on atria
is 107.
as the member designated by mr veazey
pursuant to his 965.
inform the house of mr visual about yes
on hrs 107.
as the member disney mr cohen pursuant
to hs965 and former house of mr cohen
will vote yes on hres 107.
as the member does today by ms baragon
pursuant to hs965
informing the house of ms barrigan i
will vote yesterday is 107.
as the member destinated by mr
blumenthauer pursuant to his 965.
i informed the house of mr blumenthal
will vote yes on h 107
aca res as the member designated by mr
lowenthal pursuant to hres 965 informing
that's mr lowenthal vote yes on h.j
res107
and as the member designated by mr liu
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
mr liu will vote yes on h.j res107
for what purpose does gentleman from
north carolina rise
mr speaker is a member designated by mr
price of north carolina pursuant to h
res 965
i informed the house mr price will vote
yes he will vote yes on
h.j res 107. as a member designated by
mr richmond of louisiana
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house
that mr richmond will vote yes we'll
vote yes on h
joint resolution one zero seven
for what purpose this gentleman from new
york rise
as a member designated by chairwoman
zoloft and pursuant to hres 965. i
informed the house that chairwoman
lofgren will vote yay
on hj uh res 107.
as the member designated by chairwoman
eddie bernice johnson pursuant to hres
965 i inform the house that chairwoman
johnson
will vote yay on h.j res107 as the
member designated by chairman jerry
nadler pursuant to
uh h house resolution 965 i informed the
house
that chairman nadler will vote yay on
h.j rez107
as the member designated by congressman
jose serrano
pursuant to hres 965 on former house
that congressman serrano
will vote yay on aj res107
[Music]
oh
for what purpose is gentlelady from new
york rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr deutch of florida pursuant to hres
965 i inform the house that mr deutsch
will vote
yes on h.j rez107
[Music]
proxy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
for what purpose is the gentlelady from
florida rise mr speaker as the member
designated by ms mukasel powell of
florida pursuant to hres 965
i inform the house that ms lucas alpal
will vote yay on
h.j res107 and mr speaker as the member
designated by mr hastings of florida
pursuant
to hres 965 i informed the house that mr
hastings will also vote yay on
hjres107 and mr speaker as the member
designated by mr payne of new jersey
pursuant to his 965. i inform the house
that mr payne will also vote yay
on h.j res107
[Music]
what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker remember designated by
congress member napolitano pursuant to
house resolution
965. i informed the house that congress
member napolitano of a vote yes
on h.a res 107.
and mr speaker as member designated by
congress member
costa pursuant to house resolution 965
i informed the house that congress
member costa will vote yes
on h.j rest 107.
and mr speaker as a member designated by
congressmember vargas
pursuant to house resolution 965. i
informed that house that congress member
vargas will vote yes
on hjrs107
[Music]
there you are
oh
good
what's that
uh
foreign
yes
yes
foreign
yes
you got it
for what purpose does gentleman from new
jersey rise
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr john
shimkas pursuant to hres 965
i inform the house that mr shimkas will
vote yes on h.j res107
all right
okay
yes
now
hey
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
silences
uh
now
vexing
yes
thank you
[Music]
for what purpose is gentlelady from
illinois rise
as the member designated by mr rush
pursuant to hres 965
i inform the house that mr russia vote
yes on h.j res 107.
as the member designated by ms
finkenauer pursuant to hps 965
i informed the house that miss
finkenauer will vote yes
on h.j res 107.
as a member designated by mrs chakowski
pursuant to h res 965 i informed the
house that miss schakowsky will vote yes
on h.j res107
[Music]
[Music]
prematurely
[Music]
is
[Music]
and the nays are 60 recorded as present
two-thirds being in the affirmative the
rules are suspended
the joint resolution is agreed to and
without objection the motion to
reconsider
is laid on the table
this is the gentleman for maryland rise
mr speaker i ask unanimous consent to
speak out of order for one minute
revised extend
mr speaker thank you very much uh mr
speaker i want to
notify all the members and we will
certainly do that by electronic
or by email as well but that
the negotiators trying to come to an
agreement
between the uh two parties in the house
and the senate as well
are still working very hard to reach
agreement both on the omnibus
so that we will be able to fund the
government through september 30th of
this coming year
and on the co response to covet 19
both from a health standpoint and from
an economic standpoint
we are hopeful that they will reach
agreement in the near future
they have not reached one yet there are
still some significant issues
outstanding and in light of that
i will i'm announcing that there will be
no votes tomorrow
even if an agreement were reached late
tonight
uh the administrative work necessary to
put that agreement
to memorialize it in a bill would take
at least uh 18 hours or thereabouts
so that the first and next votes that
would be
anticipated would be at one
this is a change some people had heard
two and i had used two but we're
accelerating that to 1 pm
on sunday members will receive
two hours notice for that vote so that
would mean
if it is at 1 pm you will receive a
notice at 11
a.m that ought to give time for members
who are
obviously most of whom are going to be
staying in town if they don't live close
by
uh we'll give them time to to go to
worship
and then come to the house floor
but no votes before 1am
on sunday 1 p.m on sunday
this coming sunday and notice will be
given
with two hours prior to 1 pm so by 11
and i yield back the balance of my time
this is gentleman from california seek
recognition
princess gentleman from california seek
recognition unanimous consent to dress
house one minute revise and extend my
remarks mr speaker without objection the
gentleman is recognized for one
minute this week in 1773
sam adams and the sons of liberty
organized the boston tea party one of
the most iconic protests in american
history
they dumped 342 chests of tea into the
boston harbor in an
uprising against an oppressive
government and taxation tyranny
three years ago this month republicans
built upon our founders ideals and
passed the tax cuts and jobs act
we delivered pro-growth pro-jobs
pro-america
policies to end the economic slowdown of
the previous administration
following tax reform the middle class
experienced record financial growth
household incomes soared by nearly eight
percent americans had a greater say over
their own paychecks
our founders knew lower taxes would be
better for the economy in 1773
the republicans proved that through the
tax hikes and job deck three years ago
that sam adams and the sons of liberty
were
correct are you back
for what purpose does a gentleman from
georgia seek recognition
mr speaker i ask unanimous consent to
revise and extend my remarks
without objection the gentleman is now
recognized for one minute
thank you mr speaker i rise today
mindful that i only have a few moments
to address this body from the podium so
i ask unanimous consent to place
extended remarks and materials into the
record
section as we turn our attention next
week to christmas many of us are sending
and awaiting cards and packages
let us not forget the postal workers who
deliver more than 155 billion pieces of
mail per year
which this year included our ballots in
an election that saw the largest turnout
in 100 years
for their work and commitment this
season and every holiday season
and for their extraordinary service to
our country during the pandemic i
support overtime pay
for these important civil servants and
another institution very old in our
republic
while not as old as the postal service
is morris brown college
let us resolve to support morris brown
college and contribute to the
revitalization
of the atlanta university center as we
seek to revitalize morris brown college
let us also consider ways to renew our
urban centers
a way to do that is urban farming it can
deliver produce at a lower cost leaving
families to spend
on other costs of living like housing it
can also be good for the environment as
it can reduce co2 emissions
attend it with transporting food from
far away farms to urban centers
and while we do this and we emerge from
this pandemic we must lift as we rise
and that is why we
must ensure minority and women-owned
businesses see increased participation
in our society one of the items i will
be placing in the record is a news story
from
about 27 former african-american
franchisees
who are suing mcdonald's a legendary
business for discrimination against its
own franchises
we must ensure that all in this nation
have the promise
of the american dream free from
discrimination and finally during
thank you mr speaker and i will back my
time thanks thank you
what purpose does gentleman from
california seek recognition
[Music]
[Music]
thank you mr speaker i asked unanimous
consent to address the house for one
minute and revise and extend our
remarks as necessary without objection
the gentleman is recognized for one
minute
mr speaker i rise to honor the life of
floriculturist and philanthropist
andy matsui who recently passed at the
age of 85.
after being born and raised in the
family of farmers in japan
andy got an educational visa to go to
california
and study agriculture he liked it so
much that he bought some land and
established a nursery in the salinas
valley in my district
andy produced orchids that and pioneered
the sale of potted orchids
in stores today the matsui nursery
is one of the greatest has one of the
greatest selection of orchids in the
entire world
but andy didn't just grow flowers he
grew the future for many
and he said that education is the only
way to change things
in this world that's why he and his wife
established the matsui foundation to
provide scholarships to countless
students
and andy believed in our home by
encouraging those students to not just
study
but to stay and give back to the central
coast of california
our prayers are with his family and may
andy matsui
rest in peace with the satisfaction that
he left us
with magnificent beauty from his orchids
and a magnanimous bounty
for our community thank you mr speaker i
yield back
thank you
[Music]
chairs prepared to entertain special
order speeches
[Music]
thank you guys
okay
oh
oh
pursuant to section 4b of the house
resolution 967
the house stands adjourned until noon on
sunday december twentieth
twenty twenty
you